so the word iconic it's overused isn't
it but these two fellas were literally
iconic performers for you doing the
roles was that something important for
you to avoid mannerisms impersonations
well no you sort of need to do it
there's two things you have to do you
have to sort of try and accurately
represent who they work for the people
who do know them and then but in some
ways there's this whole chasm of an area
because people although they're very
familiar there's very little detail
about who they were as people so there's
kind of all this fertile area that you
can explore that hasn't been covered
before so you have to do we have to do
two jobs sort of reflect who they were
in the way that's familiar to people and
then shine a light on the area where
people are not familiar so yeah it's not
an accident when things end up being
timeless things like a song a song
remains a timeless song because people
keep singing it
they keep listening to it and they keep
wanting to sing it wanted to hear it
and so Laurel and Hardy are timeless to
us and each generation has that since
they made their first films has gone
along and said you know what these guys
are still valuable to us so their legacy
was kept going all the time and now
Steve and I are in a wonderful position
of bringing their legacy to younger
audiences to the YouTube generation now
when we were kids we watched them on
television and then there was the
videotape generation and now you know
all of Laurel and Hardy's work is on
YouTube and it's one of the great joys
of doing with film is getting to show
people not because we're nostalgic for
Laurel and Hardy or we like the 1930s
but because their work still works as
comedy it's still very very funny so I'm
really excited for younger people who
are might not be familiar with them to
check out some of their work and our
film but mostly their work how many
people are rushing home and doing just
what you've said going onto YouTube and
having a look for the first time at
Laurel and Hardy perform and finding
actually so much is reused in comedy see
on TV now
yes I mean lasers have set the template
for a lot of comment that came
afterwards and if you watch that stuff
now it's still it still makes you laugh
because it's sort of it's strange it
lives its own its creates its own
universe its own bubble this that is
timeless and classless and you know
anyone whatever your religious political
or worldview or background cultural
background will find something to laugh
at in law and Hardy and that's quite a
that's that's a unique quality that they
have the power dynamic between these two
fellows onstage and offstage is
fascinating was that something for you
that was absolutely key to making the
film work well it's something I
understood you know having been in many
duo's many different duo's I understand
what it's like to have to be able to
pass the power to the other guy and take
it you know want to be alpha I want to
be beta it's very important it's what
makes a partnership work if you're
constantly gunning with each other to be
the top dog that might be interesting
and funny but it's it's not a very fun
day at work you know that balance that
being part of a dance where you're not
competing with your dance partner you're
trying to create a dance with your dance
partner it's very very true yeah I mean
listening to you're listening to your
partner knowing when to step back is
very important I know that because I
work with people who can trample all
over your lines and don't aren't on in
tune with you they're just doing plowing
their own 4'o regardless yeah the thing
is it's very important to listen to your
partner and not just to trample on
whatever they've just said be able to
really really listen to what they just
said but talking about dance I cannot
ignore your way out west done so I don't
want to assume but I'm guessing leader
of you had trained dancers trained yes
I'm a trained dancer yes you are now
well I did take that I studied dance
when I was in acting school sure a
trained dancer
I did a bit of movement yeah I don't say
I don't think I'm such a great dancer
but I'm gonna train I am a trained
dancer for better or worse was that fun
it was all of this stuff was a real joy
to do every day it was a great joyful
day at work even though it was hard and
I was sweating and you know it was a lot
of repetition and hours and hours in
order to get these these routines down
it was a lot of fun you know it's a
great thing to do for a living